it looks like to get in the top one
percent in order for you to get to above
five million dollars so not even top one
percent top point three percent you
gotta save like 15 grand a year for 30
years that's it and that's assuming just
nine percent returns which is just the
stock market alex how do i save twelve
hundred dollars a month most times
you're gonna wanna have to sell
something either you're selling someone
else's product or you're selling your
own product my say product i mean
product service whatever either one of
those categories and if you make a
hundred thousand dollars a year and you
live on thirty you can do this i really
believe anyone can do it you should have
to live on a lot less than you make now
if part of you is like well then what's
what's the point of living it really
depends on on what you value you can
either have your ego and how you look to
everyone or you can have your ego based
on the freedom that you feel so the
moral of this story is getting into the
top one percent is literally a matter of
saving 1500 bucks a month and putting in
the s p 500 that's it and the thing is
is it's so simple no one will do it
that's okay but you're a smart cookie
and you're going to do it because you
think that simple things are usually the
keys to the universe which i agree with
you